so are you wondering about that crazy
ending to Sunset Boulevard turns out you
aren't alone for decades audiences have
been confused about these cryptic words
the end what does that mean it turns out
it represents the ending to a movie or
another equivalent Tale But does it
leave the audience with closure yes it
does you are supposed to feel like the
movie ended which is exactly what it did
pretty clever right the words represent
the story's structural theme which is
that it is the end and the end of the
movie also what's with this crazy lady
walking down the stairs does she eat the
camera according to Billy Wilder himself
yes